en un informe de 36 páginas el
departamento de justicia de Estados
Unidos expone las razones por las cuales
allanaron la propiedad de Donald Trump
según el gobierno es probable que
documentos clasificados fueron ocultados
y retirados como parte de los esfuerzos
para obstruir la investigación sobre
Trump el departamento de Justicia
también publicó fotos de los documentos
clasificados encontrados a maralago y
embarcados por el FBI
además negó una solicitud del
expresidente para nombrar un abogado
independiente o especializado para
revisar la documentación Porque los
papeles no pertenecen a
cuando el departamento de Justicia dice
haber terminado su revisión de los
documentos sugieren que la designación
de una abogada especial ya no es
necesario o importante porque ya habían
hecho eficazmente su trabajo
el departamento de Justicia afirma que
recuperaron más de 320 documentos
clasificados en mara lago incluyendo más
de cientos de archivos encontrados por
el FBI en el último mes
Trump se enfrenta a posibles cargos de
obstrucción y acusionado el
profesionalismo del FBI el presidente
Joe biden Este martes defendió la
agencia contra los ataques partidistas
[Música]
es repugnante de ver estos nuevos
ataques contra el FBI amenazando la vida
de los agentes y sus familias
simplemente por ejecutar la ley por
haber hecho su trabajo
el departamento de Justicia dice que
Trump ha estado impulsando una narrativa
incompleta y inexacta en sus recientes
archivos judiciales mientras el ex
presidente Afirma ser la víctima de una
casa de brujas describiendo la búsqueda
del FBI como un robo